el presidente pero que yo dice que estas
dos muertes de militares no van a quedar
impunes que supone este golpe para las
fuerzas armadas de perú teniendo en
cuenta que ya el mes pasado otro soldado
murió en un ataque con en esta misma
región
bueno buenos días a todos es un golpe
muy grande a
la facción la última facción de la banda
maoísta sendero luminoso porque no es el
sol no estamos hablando de una zona en
la cual uno puede tomar bus avión o tren
es una zona en la cual no tiene que
llegar primero por río luego unas
caminatas muy grandes y al llegar al
corazón del brain de esta zona de
vizcatán la mejor manera de ver cómo
hacer una batalla es lo más parecido a
lo que fue la guerra de vietnam y eeuu
es una zona boscosa hay montañas y todo
eso ha sido tomado desde fines de los 90
por la familia quispe palomino entonces
hacer este operativo que es una
operativo que mezclan en la aviones a la
marina de guerra y a las fuentes las
fuerzas especiales del ejército
realmente es muy
importante para el estado peruano yo
creo que es independientemente del
gobierno pero castillo porque estas
operaciones se venían haciendo desde el
gobierno dejamos de ollanta humala en el
2011 y lo que significa esta operación
es la operación más importante en los
últimos 10 años en esta zona han muerto
dos jóvenes miembros del comando
conjunto de france armadas lo cual por
supuesto es muy triste y ha muerto uno
el mes pasado pero lo que está pasando
en este momento es que los tienen
ahorita por primera vez a los líderes
encima dos han llegado a uno de los
campamentos del líder de víctor quispe
palomino que se
tiene el apoyo de jose y han levantado
su digamos han llegado hasta la cama del
agarrado un arma y realmente es muy
reciente muy optimistas los policías
militares y marinos que están formando
parte de la operación señor gas cuál es
el estado actual de sendero luminoso en
el país cuántos efectivos tienen y cuál
es su presencia en el territorio
esta es la última facción de sendero
luminoso en el perú la muerte de anime
de guzmán que fue hace hace pocos meses
que significó digamos ya la caída
simbólica de esta banda de esta banda
terrorista de corte maoísta que durante
20 años asoló el país y se declaró en
contra del estado peruano cuando abimael
guzmán es capturado en 1992 en el
gobierno de alberto fujimori había una
facción rebelde en la selva norte
liderada por artemio y la facción de los
quispe palomino en la zona del vizcatán
y realmente todavía no se no se podía
declarar la derrota del de sendero
luminoso pero si se atrapa a víctor
quispe palomino y a los campamentos que
él manejaba en esta zona donde confluyen
la droga en la hoja de coca la cocaína
las armas y yo creo que allí sí se puede
declarar abiertamente que ella sendero
luminoso como tal
ya no era más el país